on le voit on est en pleine activité en
pleine ébullition le pépline de projet
est très bon en ce moment c'est que
c'est sûr que on veut qu'on veut que ça
continue les forges d'ADF roulent à
plein régime au bâti ici ce qui
deviendra une usine de batterie destinée
aux Michigan et un centre de congrès
pour la Floride nous
l'arrestation la voix pas notre commande
est en haute l'entreprise familiale de
Terrebonne comptabilise 400 millions de
dollars de nouveaux contrats depuis
décembre une croissance étonnante un peu
à l'image de l'économie canadienne on va
pas de projets qui sont retardés ou des
projets qui sont assez vers la droite
encore les hausses des taux directeurs
canadiens et américains ont épargnés la
production de ce Florent québécois
reconnu notamment pour avoir érigé
l'antenne au sommet du works Center
c'est des croissances quand même plus
fortes que ce qu'anticiper la Banque du
Canada donc elle pourrait être tentée
d'augmenter les taux à la lumière de ce
qui s'est passé au niveau du PIB
l'économie canadienne a déjoué tous les
pronostics au premier trimestre propulsé
par ses exportations et surtout une
consommation soutenue les économies sont
été surpris les attentes étaient plus
basse que le 3 points 1% de croissance
pour Ali et Marianne deux étudiants dans
la jeune vingtaine sont donne à cœur
joie j'en ai vraiment pas beaucoup des
shorts coût de la vie oblige elle se
montre plus raisonnable sans se priver
du petit plaisir de rafraîchir leur
garde-robe estivale j'ai pas d'enfants
non plus à ma charge je sais que ça ça
change beaucoup
d'argent parce que j'ai juste moi à
m'occuper personne d'autre
on se garde dans la mesure du possible
dans l'intelligence
des dépenses se font doucement sentir
mon argent quand je le dépense ce que je
vais recevoir en échange le plus l'avoir
choisi je vais plus avoir le chérir
aussi je pense peut-être vraiment besoin
de ça en ce moment j'ai absolument pas
besoin de ça en ce moment
de plus en plus de Canadiens doivent
maintenant s'endetter pour subvenir à
leurs besoins le solde de leur carte de
crédit a augmenté de 11%, présage d'un
ralentissement prochain oui je suis
relativement optimiste qu'on va revenir
dans la fourchette de 1 à 3% de la
Banque du Canada dans un avenir assez
prévisible je vous dirai cet été
nos employés travaillent on pourrait
même embaucher encore plus en ce moment
même s'ils sont plus de 350 employés à
l'usine de Terrebonne c'est un robot
soudeur de poutres qui a sauvé les
meubles l'automne dernier il fait à lui
seul le travail d'une centaine
d'employés des travailleurs qualifiés
que l'entreprise est incapable de
recruter c'est sûr qu'encore le mot
récession sur certaines lèvres le mot
fait peur pour nous ça c'est le scénario
qu'on veut pas voir se réaliser avec le
recul du secteur de la construction la
demande pour les structures en acier et
peut-être sur le point de vaciller ici
Jean-Philippe piouze Radio-Canada
Terrebonne